>> Laura: TIME NOW FOR OUR
SEEN AND UNSEEN SEGMENT.
SOMEONE JUST RAN BEHIND THE
SIDE.
ORSON WELLES.
THIS IS FUN.
IT'S LIVE TV.
RIGHT?
I THINK THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT
FUN.
YOU KNOW IT'S LIVE.
ON TAFT MADE THE ORWELLIAN
NIGHTMARE OF SOCIALIZED MEDICINE
EXPOSED BY THE PLIGHT OF A DYING
CHILD.
KANYE WEST STRIKES AGAIN, MAKING
LIBERAL HEADS SPIN.
TO PUT IT ALL IN PERSPECTIVE, WE
ARE JOINED BY FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND ARROYO.
THE MEDIA COVERAGE OF THE
FIRST LADY YESTERDAY, FOCUSED ON
HER HAT.
>> HER HAT.
STEPHEN COLBERT KIND OF CAPTURED
IT IN THIS CLIP.
WATCH.
>> TODAY THE TWO MEN ADDRESSED
THE CROWD, AND THERE WAS AN
AWKWARD MOMENT.
TRUMP GOES FOR THE KISS AND OH!
SAVED BY THE HACK.
THAT'S MORE THAN A HALF.
THAT'S A DEFENSIVE PERIMETER.
THEIR DEAL IS EITHER SHE GETS TO
WEAR THE HAT OR TRUMP HAS TO
WEAR A CONE.
>> Laura: WE CALL IT THE CONE
OF SHAME ON MY DOG.
>> THERE WAS MAINSTREAM COVERAGE
OF THIS IDEA.
THE NARRATIVE IS THAT THE TERMS
ARE DISTANT.
THEY ARE LOVELESS.
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
>> Laura: WHAT ARE THEY
SUPPOSED TO DO, MAKE OUT IN
FRONT OF EVERYBODY QUESTION REX
TO GO THEY ARE DEPRIVING MELANIA
OF A REALLY IMPORTANT MOMENT.
THIS MOMENT YESTERDAY.
MICHELLE OBAMA WHEN SHE WAS
RUNNING THE WHITE HOUSE OR LAURA
BUSH BEFORE HER, THEY HAD TEAMS
OF PEOPLE, HUNDREDS, TO
ORGANIZE.
>> Laura: PROFESSIONAL PARTY
PLANNERS.
DESIREE ROGERS SCREWED UP AT THE
STATE DINNER AND PEOPLE SNUCK
IN.
REMEMBER THAT?
>> MELANIA TRUMP OF THIS ALL ON
HER OWN.
SHE ASSEMBLED A TEAM OF TEN
PEOPLE, JUST HER STAFF.
IT'S HER STAFF.
SHE WENT OVER THE PROTOCOL.
>> Laura: THE VIDEO OF HER.
>> SHE CHOSE THE FLOWERS,
LIGHTS, WHOLE THING.
SHE SHOULD BE GIVEN CREDIT FOR
THAT, NOT MALIGNED, NOT GRABBING
THE HAND WHEN IT WAS PRESENTED.
SHE DID HOLD HIS HAND.
SHE DID INDEED LET HIM KISS HER.
THIS NARRATIVE, I AM TIRED OF
THIS NARRATIVE.
>> Laura: THEY CANNOT GIVE HER
ONE MOMENT.
THIS WAS AN ELEGANT, WONDERFUL,
BEAUTIFUL PRESENTATION OF
AMERICA TO FRANCE, AND WITH THE
FRENCH TOUCH AND THE NEW ORLEANS
STUFF.
>> JAMBALAYA.
>> Laura: I DON'T WANT TO
MENTION NEW ORLEANS.
I WAVE AT EVERYBODY.
>> DON'T WAVE IT ME.
>> Laura: I LIKE THAT WE ARE
IN DOUBLE BOXES.
ALFIE EVANS, THIS IS ANOTHER
INFURIATING CASE.
NATIONAL HEALTH SERVICE IN
BRITAIN IS PREVENTING PARENTS
FROM GIVING MEDICAL ASSISTANCE
TO THEIR CHILD.
THIS IS SO HEARTBREAKING.
SPEAK OF THE SUBTLE BOY CAME IN
DECEMBER OF 2016.
HE WAS PART OF THE HOSPITAL WITH
AN INFECTION.
HE'S BEEN ON A RESPIRATOR.
THEY SAY IF YOU TAKE THE
RESPIRATOR OUT, HE WOULD DIE.
HE WOULD BE ABLE TO BREATHE ON
HIS OWN.
WELL, IT'S BEEN OUT SINCE
MONDAY.
HIS PARENTS FOUGHT TO KEEP THE
RESPIRATOR.
>> Laura: THEY DON'T WANT TO
PAY THE MONEY?
THEY DON'T WANT TO SPEND THE
MONEY?
>> NATIONAL HEALTH SERVICE IN
BRITAIN, THEY LOOK AT AN
ACTUARIAL TABLE AND THEY SAY --
>> Laura: NOT A HUMAN LIFE.
>> DOES THE COST EXCEED THE
QUALITY OF LIFE?
IN THE CASE OF VISIBLE BABY WHO
HAS A DEGENERATIVE BRAIN
DISEASE, THEY SAY SHOULD BE CUT
OFF.
NO MORE CARE.
PARENTS ARE FIGHTING.
THEY WANT THEM TO HAVE CARE.
THE FATHER WENT TO SEE THE POPE
LAST WEEK.
IN DESPERATION.
THE POPE NOT ONLY BLESSED HIS
EFFORTS, HE INTERCEDED.
THE POPE SAID THE HEAD OF A
CLINIC IN ROME TO LIVERPOOL,
ENGLAND.
SHE IS STANDING THERE, THE
DOCTORS WON'T MEET WITH HER.
THERE'S A MEDICAL JET WAITING TO
TAKE THIS CHILD TO ITALY TO GET
MEDICAL TREATMENT.
>> Laura: THE POPE WANTS TO
TAKE THE BABY AND HELP THE BABY
AND THE NATIONAL HEALTH SERVICE
WON'T LET THE POPE AND GIVE HIM
ITALIAN CITIZENSHIP TWO.
>> THEY WON'T LET HIM FREE.
WHY?
I WILL TELL YOU WHY.
IT'S A SHAME.
IT WOULD BE A BLIGHT ON THE FACE
OF THIS NATIONAL HEALTH CARE
WHICH HAS BECOME ITS OWN
RELIGION.
>> Laura: DEHUMANIZED.
>> TO HAVE A CITIZEN GO
ELSEWHERE FOR MEDICAL CARE.
THEY WOULD RATHER LET THE CHILD
DIED IN HOSPITAL.
>> Laura: THE CHILD IS
SUFFERING NOW BECAUSE IT'S BEING
DENIED FOOD AND HYDRATION AS
WELL OR FOOD?
STICKER THEY ARE GIVING IT SOME
HYDRATION.
LET ME TELL YOU, THE NETWORKS IN
THE UNITED STATES TO A
28 MINUTES OF COVERAGE OF THE
ROYAL BIRTH.
NONE TO ALFIE EVANS.
>> Laura: THE QUEEN MADE A
STATEMENT.
>> WILLIAM AND KATE AS WELL.
LOTS OF PRAYER SERVICES
HAPPENING AROUND THE COUNTRY.
IN NEW YORK TOMORROW AT NOON AT
THE U.N., ALSO NOTRE DAME TODAY
AND OTHER SCHOOLS.
>> Laura: WELL.
LET'S PRAY FOR A MIRACLE HERE.
PRAY FOR A MIRACLE.
ALL RIGHT, THIS HAVE THE TWITTER
SPHERE GOING CRAZY.
I'M GLAD IT'S NOT FOCUSED ON ME.
I'M GLAD WHEN I AM NOT TRENDING.
WHAT IS TRENDING IS KANYE WEST
WHO I HAD A PROBLEM WITH WHEN HE
TOOK TAYLOR SWIFT'S AWARD OUT OF
HER HAND.
REMEMBER THAT IDEAL?
IT'S KANYE.
>> HE IS A FREE --
>> Laura: HE WAS A PAL OF
TRUMP.
>> HE ISSUED THIS WEEK TODAY
WHICH READS:  OF COURSE "THE MAK
WHICH READS:  OF COURSE "THE MAE
AMERICA GREAT" HAT.
HE CAME OUT AND SAID NO MOM IS
GOING TO DISSUADE HIM FROM THAT
LOVE.
HE IS BEING ATTACKED, AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE.
>> Laura: MUST HAVE WATCHED
OUR "DEFENDING THE FIRST" SERIES
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN DEFENDING
PEOPLE'S RIGHTS TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT OPINION.
>> I AM OF 2 MINDS.
>> Laura: YOU'RE A BIG HIP-HOP
FAN.
RIGHT UP WITH FRANK SINATRA.
>> HERE'S THE IDEA, I'M NOT SURE
IF HE'S TRYING TO PROMOTE HIS
UPCOMING ALBUMS AND HIS LINE,
LINE OF CLOTHING OR IF IT'S
TRULY A CRY FOR FREEDOM OF
SPEECH AND MIGHT BE AN OPENING
IN A COMMUNITY THAT'S BEEN
MONOLITHIC.
WE'LL SEE.
CHANCE THE RAPPER CAME OUT AND
SET UP NOT ALL BLACK PEOPLE HAVE
TO BE DEMOCRATS.
TAKING A CHANCE.
THERE IT IS.
WE WILL SEE WHERE IT LEADS.
HOPEFULLY IT WILL START A
CONVERSATION.
WHY CAN'T THERE BE WHITE
LIBERALS AND WHITE CONSERVATIVES